l'avenir appartient à ceux qui ne se
lève pas hier le cdh états ouais ça veut
dire est que si je sais ce que ça veut
dire de plus
c'est quoi cette ambiance crafton là
j'ai quoi le fait qu'il vient vers nous
la ressentons dégagement mais la méthode
apparaître des recettes hors carte est
sérieux ou pas des succès comme les
chevaux ils sentent si tu as peur d'un
canot tous temps les actes à cash qui
joue dans ta bouche tu me casses les
couilles jim pouillon fait quoi quand
mayer dont la route est bloquée monsieur
faut évacuer le secteur articulé je
comprends pas un problème
on n'est pas de on est pas de problème
on avait maintenant un match on va faire
une marche arrière fin de journée en
journée
c'est vraiment un gros court j'ai avalé
les trucs là t'es vraiment un gros
contre